on l'appelle la charte du gruyère au
fond il y aurait pas fallu la payer
charte parce qu'on a l'impression de
serrer les gens dans un corset
des organisations agricoles dans la
production à venir du comté rue du
gruyère
[Musique]
dimanche matin et Benoît 450 habitants
700 mètres d'altitude un village de
Franche-Comté où les agriculteurs sont
de moins en moins nombreux fin avril il
y a encore de la neige 11h du matin pas
âme qui vivent dans les rues tout est
peignoir est à la messe
à la sortie de la messe on se retrouve
et on discute dans la rue pas de bistrot
à proximité de l'église
l'autre point de ralliement c'est la
fruitière c'est à dire la coopérative
laitière le chalet là où chaque éleveur
apporte le lait de la dernière traite
[Musique]
ment
soleil sera pesé filtré comptabilisé
analysé de temps à autre avant d'être
versée dans les cuves ou ses laborera le
fromage de compte
pour fabriquer du comté il faut chauffer
le lait ici c'est à la vapeur produite
par une chaudière classique le bois est
pour rien à epenois
à epenois il y a un maître fromager il
est logé il est payé en fonction du
chiffre d'affaires de la fruitière il a
des aides qu'il paie lui-même il lui
reste net par mois quelques 3000 francs
au bas mot quand la pâte est faite il
faut l'extrait
il faut la tenir sous presse pendant 24
heures
puis faire reposer les meules ainsi
obtenus sur des clés pendant un mois
elles seront salées et recalées avant
d'être envoyé dans les caves d'affinage
à Besançon
[Musique]
dimanche fin de l'après-midi voici la
maison du président de la fruitière
Narcisse Bouvresse
[Musique]
et puis
voici les tables et c'est 30 vaches
laitières des montbéliards
on l'appelle la charte du gruyère au
fond il y aurait pas fallu la payer
charte parce qu'on a l'impression de
serrer les gens dans un corset
des organisations agricoles dans la
production à venir du comté rue du
gruyère et en quelques mots en trois
points à quoi ça consiste bah écoutez le
premier point qui a fait surtout plus
réagir c'est le point de la
concentration on a vu que ce point là
concentration d'exploitation des
fruitiers la concentration des
exploitations se fait toute seule mais
la constatation des fruitières qui est
un mot qui a fait certainement réagir
beaucoup de gens mais c'est pas là s'il
n'y avait qu'un concentré pour avoir un
prix de produits c'est trop facile mais
on a voulu dans cette charte prévoir la
concentration qui est un point mais
surtout la commercialisation derrière et
nous n'aurions pas que la coopération
soit en position de faiblesse en face du
secteur industriel qui est qui lui est
dynamique
la commercialisation c'est l'affaire de
l'Union coopérative des fruitières de
Franche-Comté qui écoule 40% de la
production totale de la région
dans des caves d'affinage repose des
milliers de meule chaque meule porte un
double numéro matricule celui de la
fruitière d'où elle vient et un numéro
individuel chaque meule est en effet
classé en extra sur choix ou deuxième
choix et les producteurs sont d'autant
plus payés que leurs fruitières a réussi
à fournir un grand nombre de molles
extra chaque meule de comté est en outre
authentifié par un label
jusqu’ici il était impensable de vendre
du comté autrement qu'en meule
aujourd'hui pour satisfaire les grandes
surfaces de vente il faut pré-emballer
sous plastique le comté en portion pesée
étiquetée et toute prête à être vendues
est-ce l'avenir va-t-on vers une
industrialisation totale de la
fabrication du Comté monsieur Perrin le
directeur général de l'Union coopérative
des fruitières de Franche-Comté et
partagez à mon avis il existe
actuellement deux marchés potentiels en
ce qui concerne les fromages pressés les
fromages de genre gruyère et mental
de marché qui s'adressent à des
clientèles différentes la clientèle de
masse qui veut des fromages
de qualité banale et puis les les
gourmets les gens qui s'intéressent à
ces fromages dont je vous parlais tout à
l'heure de qualité spécifique bien
originale
et je crois qu'il y a une option à faire
savoir si on veut s'orienter à la
production vers l'un ou l'autre de ces
marchés
une production de masse de qualité
banale destinée aux hypermarchés comme
celui-ci situé à l'ouest de Paris où le
comté se vend comme des petits pains
voici à ce sujet l'opinion de Monsieur
Fournier le directeur adjoint le gruyère
est parmi les fromages celui qui est le
plus vendu en masse en tonnage
nous avons ici 180 sortes de fromages et
les mental occupent dans nos rayons une
longueur de 5 mètres
[Musique]
le public qui vient
chercher du fromage et qui choisit de
l’emmental et certainement plus exigeant
sur d'autres fromages que sur les mental
dans ce magasin nous faisons un tonnage
de 5 tonnes à la semaine
[Musique]
le comté doit-il être au contraire un
produit de luxe écoutons monsieur
Lefebvre membre de la confrérie des
tasses fromages et crémiers place de la
Madeleine à Paris au point de
fabrication au point de vue goût surtout
il y a beaucoup plus de
caractères dans un fromage fermier que
dans un fromage
industriel évidemment ce que les gens
font une différence entre les mental le
comté
Beaufort oui bien qu'ils engloquent tous
ces fromages à pâte cuite sous le nom de
Gruère mais il y a quand même une
différence entre les fromages il
demanderont du comté ou du Beaufort de
l'Emmental ou du Fribourg ou du gruyère
véritable Fribourg votre avis est-ce que
il est possible de continuer à faire du
compter très personnalisé dans des
grandes unités de production
ce sera à voir mais je pense que tant
qu'il y aura des petits fabricants et
des
petits fabricants qui fabriquons de la
belle marchandise de la bonne
marchandise ce sera cependant très très
bien il y a actuellement des clients qui
sont prêts à payer plus cher pour un
programme de qualité ah oui un
discutablement il préfère mettre le prix
et avoir quelque chose de propre et de
bon
5 tonnes par semaine d'un côté 150 kg
d'un autre côté quelle option choisir
aux Rousses dans le Jura les animateurs
de la fruitière messieurs Louis
Chevassus et Gérard Brodard notamment on
fait leur choix ils veulent rester entre
eux continuer à fabriquer leur fromage
extra et ils ont de bonnes raisons nous
pensons avoir aux Rousses quand même une
situation un petit peu
qui n'est pas comme les autres sociétés
comme dans les autres sociétés est-ce
que vous vendez bien votre produit très
bien nous pensons régler cette année
autour de 65 francs le lait cet hiver
nous producteurs alors nous nous voyons
pas pourquoi nous irions ailleurs ça
c'est votre opinion vous êtes président
de cette fruitière est-ce que c'est
l'opinion aussi des adhérents
rien ne vous dit que dans une grande
unité de production
vous n'aurez pas des conditions de prix
aussi avantageuse en doute que ces
conditions sont moins avantageuses
premièrement parce que un transport est
toujours coûteux
d'ailleurs la qualité du lait du lait
transporté du labrassé n'est jamais
aussi bonne que du lait qui arrive à la
fromagerie par les sociétés humaines
la société des Russes commercialise pas
mal de ses produits les patentées en
yaourt en fromage blanc et ainsi de
suite
je crois qu'elle fait le maximum pour
assurer une rentabilité les plus
importantes à ces adhérents vous êtes
contre cette charte du gruyère et contre
les conséquences qu'elle pourrait avoir
chez vous pourtant cette charte a été
signée par un ensemble de dirigeants
agricoles est-ce que vous avez été avant
la signature informée est-ce qu'on est
venu vous demander votre avis
officiellement non on a pris par les
journaux comme c'est comme ça mais
officiellement n'a pas on n'a pas
déconsulté il n'y a pas eu de débat non
rien du tout
est-ce que si vous aviez été mieux
informé est-ce que vous auriez peut-être
mieux compris la portée de cette femme
peut-être mieux compris mais je crois
que notre idée n'aurait quand même pas
changé vu notre situation géographique
cette position est partagée par beaucoup
de coopérateurs de Franche-Comté près de
Pontarlier on passe aux actes une
première centrale Laitière et déjà en
construction elle regroupera 13
fruitières ces promoteurs expliquent
pourquoi les ateliers de fabrication
sont à très anciens souvent à partir de
même à la commune ont besoin de
travaux à grand frais
et il y a aussi le problème des
fromagers quoi qu'il que même le cache
très bien mais ils ont beau le cacher il
y a quand même un grand problème du côté
de la main d'oeuvre c'est à dire c'est à
dire que ces gens travaillent 365 jours
par an
sans remplacement
alors on le sent très bien venir
qu'on sera obligé de faire quelque chose
pour le ramener à notre genre de travail
c'est à dire de d'avoir des vacances des
congés comme tout le monde donc
augmenter encore la main d'oeuvre
augmenter la main d'oeuvre alors comme
les ateliers ne sont pas assez ne sont
pas assez conséquents pour avoir deux
employés en général
par leur groupement on économiser pas
mal de personnes mais ici avec tous ces
investissements combien ça représente
d'investissement ici par exemple grosso
modo 250 millions d'investissements 250
millions de ces investissements pendant
les amortir est-ce que vous ne pensez
pas que le prix de revient d'un kilo de
comté sera au moins aussi cher que dans
une petite coopérative il sera moins
cher
ce système ne va pas obliger les
agriculteurs à faire long chemin pour
venir à la coopérative non c'est le
contraire
puisque le camion ramasse le lait à
domicile deux fois par jour qu'une fois
par jour puisque le lait refroidi à la
ferme au contraire le cultivateur est
moins soumis aux heures de retraite
puisqu'il peut se faire librement le
camion passe chercher son lait dans la
journée la condition qu'il a un temps
réfrigérant dans les anciennes sociétés
de fromagerie ou dans les fermes chez
les particuliers parce qu'on pense qu'il
faut un minimum de 100000 litres de lait
année par exploitation par exploitation
pour que ça mérite de d'avoir un tant
que refroidisseur à la ferme et on
n'avait pas encore là bien loin
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
en qualité il restera des fruitières les
petites fruitières qui continueront à
faire un produit de luxe il y a pas de
doute il y a les conditions climatiques
de notre région qui sont pour une part
puisque dans la haute montagne il sera
très difficile de faire des ramassages
étant donné les hauteurs
bien sûr il y a beaucoup de choses à
remettre en ordre à réorganiser depuis
le stade de la transformation jusqu'à la
commercialisation nous devons pas c'est
par la concentration pour accroître
notre pouvoir économique sur le marché
et ainsi améliorer le revenu des
agriculteurs
voilà donc le dossier du compte voilà
les questions soulevées par cette
fameuse charte signée le 7 février
dernier par 21 responsables
d'organisations agricoles
le moins que l'on puisse dire c'est que
tout n'est pas résolu la discussion
reste ouverte
[Musique]